Kate Middleton recycles another elegant  dress that's tennis star Serena Williams  meeting the 34 year old royal at  Wimbledon on Thursday Kate was on hand  to watch Serena compete and win in day  10 of the tennis championships the  Duchess of Cambridge was a showstopper  in this vibrant and classy yellow dress  by Roxanne de elenchi and she paired the  brave Brock with a pair of neat pumps  but it's not the first time Kate has  worn this dress here she is in the same  color-block look in 2014 visiting the  Sydney Opera House in Australia with her  royal hubby Prince William and always  the fashionista Kate wowed in this  ivory-colored  off the shoulder dress on Wednesday she  looked effortlessly elegant as she  showed up to the Natural History Museum  in London to present an award but back  Thursday's fun look we totally get why  she'd wear this dress twice